hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled dynamic live cell imaging
of adherent and immune cells using cell
asic onyx ii microfluidic platform this
webinar is part of the cell bio 2021 and
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
millipore sigma for more information
about millipore stigma go to
www.sigmaaltrich.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate first by communicating with
our attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find this live chat located at the right
hand side of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
you have time for at the end of the
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on that help desk button located
at the bottom of your screen with the
navigation bar or from the lobbies
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr june park a
senior scientist at miller poor sigma
for a complete biography of dr park
please visit the biography tab at the
top
left of your screen
welcome dr park you may now begin your
presentation sir
hello my name is drew park and i'm one
of the r d managers at millipursuma
today i would like to present dynamic
lifestyle imaging about urine and immune
cells using our selasik platform
here is the outline of today's
presentation
i'll start with the basics and
challenges associated with setting up
dynamic lifestyle imaging
i will then give a brief intro to our
turnkey select platform which enables
dynamic lifestyle imaging with any
existing inverted microscopes
main part of the presentation today will
be applications demonstrating the
utility of the cellulasic system with
particular emphasis given to suspension
cells such as t lymphocytes which play
crucial role in immuno oncology
let's start with some background
information on dynamic life cell imaging
i think by now it is very well
established that lifestyle imaging
offers tremendous biological insight
over traditional static imaging due to
spatial and temporal information
for example here we are showing the
static image of t lymphocytes loaded
with a fluorescent calcium indicator dye
at this point not much inside can be
gained perhaps other than what appears
to be different level of fluorescence
among the t cells
now if we were to take time-lapse image
of these t-cells
as shown in the bottom of the slide
we start to gain deeper level of
understanding
to the spatial temporal dynamics of
these cells at single cell level
in this particular experiment t cells
were activated with ionomycin which
causes increasing intracellular calcium
level
already couple observations can be made
which were not possible but we're just
looking at the static image in the
middle of the slide
for example we can notice that t cells
are oscillating at their calcium level
during the resting stage
and also that there is a significant
level of heterogeneity among the t cells
in terms of their costly responses upon
activation
let's play the movie itself to better
appreciate what is going on
in summary the advantages of dynamic
lifestyle imaging can be summarized in
this slide
analysis cellular event at single cell
level
thus enabling study of population
heterogeneity
study of cellular biology as a function
of microenvironmental perturbations
for example we can study calcium
responses of t-cells before
during and after their activation
another common example would be dynamic
gas control such as cycling between
democracy and hypoxic conditions
last but not least is the time dimension
where we can now study various cellular
responses such as morphology movement
signaling
as well as a cell cell interaction
as a function of time to obtain spatial
temporal information of any given
biological system
now let's take a step back
and think about some of the challenges
in terms of building or buying a system
which will enable dynamic lifestyle
imaging
dynamic lifestyle imaging while it is a
very powerful tool has its challenges
this is an image from wikipedia and
nicely demonstrates the complexity of
such a system
these are very large and complex systems
with a high price tag
requiring well-trained scientists to
operate
also in all cases additional
do-it-yourself components are required
to enable perfusion and fluid
capabilities in order to create true
dynamic imaging system
these components such as pumps and
proficient chambers with associated
controllers will further create
complexity and increase price
switching gears then uh let's talk about
our celesic platform
what would be the key advantages of our
system
to start it is a true turnkey product
with integrated environmental control
system coupled to microfluidic plate
where cells will be cultured and imaged
the system controller shown in the
middle of the slide is the size of a
typical 13-inch laptop in its x and y
dimension
it is extremely portable and was built
with mobility in mind
the controller controls various
parameters such as temperature gas and
flow rate within the microfluidics plate
which is connected to the controller by
manifold
the software is very easy to use and
enables step step protocol building
where each experimental step can be
built with user-defined time temperature
gas and proficient parameter such as
flow rate
let's take a look at the plate
in greater details
it has standard 96 well footprint
image in the center show
one of our plate pre-loaded with colored
dies to show individual layout of the
fluidics
plate has a 16 knot oils on the left
side and two outlet wells on the right
side
connected to the central tissue culture
chamber area via microfluidics channel
as you can see in this cartoon for each
role indicators are group 1 2 3 and 4
all the individual well within the group
are connected to tissue culture chamber
area via individual microfluidics
channels which are the colored lines
this enables up to four independent
experiments to be conducted per plate
when the plane is connected to the
controller unit vr manifold media or
reagent in each of the inlet wells can
be pressed down via positive pressure
this will then move the media or reagent
from that well into the tissue culture
chamber area
and which will then will exit to the
outer wells
essentially this creates a system where
any desired media or reagent can be
precisely delivered to cells in the
chamber area
at desired time
for specific duration and with specific
flow rate
since the plate can be temperature and
gas control
we now have a system that can offer
ability to control cellular micro
environment in dynamic on demand fashion
plate material is also made of gas
permeable polymer to allow dynamic gas
control
and the bottom of the plate is made of
n1.5 glass for clear imaging including
confocal applications
last thing i would like to mention is
that since these are microfluidics plate
we can also introduce specific micro
dimensional features
targeting certain applications such as
imaging of suspension cells or
maintenance of chemotactic gradient
now let's go over some of the key
applications
our system can be connected to two
independent gas outlets
so in this example we can create nomoxy
and hypoxic conditions using gas
switching ability
the middle image shows fluorescent
intensity of reverse oxygen sensor rtdp
measured from one of the tissue culture
chamber within our microfluidic plate
rttp will increase fluorescence with
decreasing oxygen concentration and vice
versa
arrows indicate the time point at which
gas switching was initiated
we can see rtdp fluorescence increasing
as we put tissue chamber under hypoxic
condition
starting at t equals two hours
when we revert to no maxi condition
at t equals 6.5 hours we can see
fluorescence start to decrease
now that we have established that our
system can create hypoxic or nomoxic
microenvironment
the image on the right shows cellular
responses under such conditions by
measuring expression level of heatphone
alpha which is a key transcription
factor under cellular hypoxia
we are also measuring itdp fluorescence
as indicated by blue line
when cells are subjected to hypoxic
condition
we see the expression level of heatphone
alpha increasing as seen by the increase
in the black line
and then later on as cells are subjected
to the maxi condition we see
fluorescence of rtdp decreasing which in
turn is followed rapidly by decreased
expression of hyphen alpha
intensity of dappy is plotted as a
control in purple line
and it shows no meaningful change under
changing oxygen levels
next we would like to show you lifestyle
movie generated using biotracker hypoxia
lifestyle dye this is a cell permeable
lifestyle dye which becomes fluorescent
under hypoxic condition inside of cells
here we're looking at a431 cells
loaded with and without dye after 16
hour incubation under hypoxic condition
to show its specificity
now let's take a look at the livestream
movie
next we will look at the autophagosomes
formation under hypoxia using
fluorescent lysosomal marker lc3
under hypoxic condition
cellular stress will induce the
formation of punctate autophagosomes
and this can be visualized and measured
based on lifestyle imaging
let's take a look at the movie
next applications we're looking at
intracellular trafficking of proteins
in this case
we are examining internalization of
fluorescent egf receptor upon egf
activation you will notice upon the
addition of egf the receptors start to
collapse together which then gets
internalized to endosomal compartment
with characteristic punctate patterns
let's take a look at the lifestyle movie
while the migration and innovation
is widely performed on membrane
platforms
did not allow life cell imaging for
obvious reasons
here we now show how microfluidics
can enable live cell imaging of cellular
migration
while maintaining chemotactic gradient
we have a microfluidics culture chamber
that is connected to two parallel flow
channels
cells are cultured in the middle chamber
and chemoattractant is perfused into an
adjacent channel
as you can see in the images at the
bottom
cells will migrate towards the presence
of chemoattractant
let's take a look
perhaps most obvious utility of dynamic
lifestyle imaging is calcium imaging
many cell types respond to external
stimulation by increasing intracellular
calcium level often these calcium
responses are transient responses which
only last for short duration of time
bottom images of the slide show calcium
responses of hela cells to atp
and you can see that the response occurs
within a minute of atp introduction
imaging this type of rapid transient
responses require on-demand dynamic
imaging capability
now let's take a closer look at the atp
induced calcium responses
of healer cells
we will cover one more example of
calcium imaging where cells are
undergoing rapid spontaneous calcium
oscillation
emission the rise shows
cardiac muscle cells undergoing a
spontaneous contraction
with life cell imaging we can better
understand the temporal dynamics of such
behavior
images on the left show calcium
fluctuation of individual cells over
time
we can see that the cells are actually
beating every two to three seconds as
seen by the ups and downs of the calcium
level let's take a closer look at the
livestream movie
next i would like to cover lifestyle
imaging of suspension cells
which pose unique challenge due to their
non-other hearing nature
as you can see on the image at the
bottom left
during life cell imaging suspension
cells will move up and down making it
impossible to image cells at single cell
level
however if we introduce micro scale
ceiling then we can confine the cells
under single focal plane and enable
clear visualization of cells during life
cell imaging
now we can use this micro sealing
feature
to examine in great detail cell cell
interaction of t cells with that of
antigen presenting b cells
let's take a closer look
here's another example where we're
examining t cell appetizers at single
cell level
we're using cd95 activation to induce
programmed cell death and then
visualizing the cellular events using
caspase-3 specific apoptosis probe as
well as annexing 5. let's take a look at
the livestream movie
i would like to close the application
part with 3d live cell imaging
we know that currently 3d tissue
culturing is very hot topic
shown on the left side are images of mcf
cells
grown in our microfluidic plate compared
to a regular chamber slide
let's take a closer look at how these
cells form 3d structures in our plate
in closing out
i would like to mention some additional
features of our system
in addition to dynamic lifestyle imaging
it can be used as an automation platform
for tasks such as staining
we can also enable extraction of cells
after imaging for example trypsinite
cells can be interrogated by flow
cytometry
proteins or nucleic acid can also be
collected and analyzed as
well that covers our applications
overview
now for summary i would like to quickly
go over our plate offerings
we have number plates targeted for
different cell types
so all our plates that start with letter
m are intended for mammalian imaging
whereas our plates with letter b and y
are intended for bacteria and east
imaging respectively
we do enjoy a tremendous number of
publications many of them in top
journals further demonstrating the value
that we bring for our customers
now in summary
we know that the real in vivo biology is
complex and dynamic
an ability to perform dynamic life cell
imaging
offers unique window of opportunity to
better understand these events
with celasic we can now better control
the dynamic cellular micro environment
with turnkey offering leveraging
microfluidics
our system enables wide range of studies
which can better recapitulate complex
individual biology
with that i would like to thank everyone
if you have any questions please do not
hesitate to contact us or visit us at
www.cell
thank you
you